this border market used to be a thriving
commercial hub
it's now a shell of its former self
it was known for cheap imports like rice
automobiles and garments
but not anymore it's been six months
since nigeria reopened its western land
border with benin
but people like successful motorcycle
dealer omolyo inua say
they're having to find other work to
make a living
and he's not happy if the government
tells you the brotherhood closed they
are telling lie
because somebody something is opened it
gives free passage
of goods and people at that place by the
time you get to the border now because
that border is not
opened it's remained closed clues
because he partially opened it
to some group of people in this country
he says such favours have ruled small
businesses like his
and by extension have hurt the economy
the head of a local traders union agrees
no movement for market there's little
activities at the market
even the number of visitors reduced
substantially with incomes wiped out
people stay at home and as such you
can't get the taxes
residents say even passenger traffic is
not what it used to be
the border closure was meant to reduce
the import of food items to encourage
domestic growth
and stop the smuggling of firearms and
illicit drugs into nigeria
but after one and a half years the
president admits that more arms came in
during the ban raising questions as to
what it actually achieved
border officials however insist the
shutdown was a resounding success
as there is cross-border collaboration
and sharing of intelligence
on smuggling there were a lot of
seizures
of prohibited items that would have
found their ways into the country
through illegal routes and all that
there were also
arrests of irregular migrants
which could have complicated the
security situations
but enforcing the border rules has made
it more expensive to live in communities
like semi
people here say numerous checkpoints are
hurting the transportation of goods
from across the border in other parts of
nigeria
the government reopened its borders just
as the free trade agreement facilitated
by the african union
was coming into force but months later
business activity here has yet to pick
up
nigeria's government has accused its
neighbors of endangering not only its
economy
but also its security saying weapons and
ammunition
still flow across the borders to feed
its ever-growing conflicts
mohammed idris al-jazeera semi on
nigeria benin border